agora 32 11 h
não tem mal a todo o pessoal aqui quem
fala é dar preciso muito bem-vindos
amazon web othon o estrago de que mais
um vídeo e como esperam ver pelo título
hoje nós vamos fazer expulsões do forte
na pessoal infelizmente ou felizmente
estou muito feliz se algum jogo que o
fortunato inclusive se vocês quiserem
ficar comigo
adicionei está há um ano em baixa o nome
do jogo é neste remoto solo e vão jogar
juntos é portanto muito difícil eu tive
uma idéia no outro dia e enquanto estava
a jogar por lá existem muitas opções são
opções que dão escudo e eu pensei por
que não fazer essas funções na vida real
porque eu estou muito bonitas elas têm
assim uma cor azul com um brilho muito
bonito mesmo então eu vou fazer isso
aqui na vida real aí pra quem não sabe o
que é o torneio que for vai ter um jogo
tipo de sobrevivência onde existem
sempre eles uns contra os outros e
também queremos fazer equipes de
batalhar também contra outras equipes
então meu é muito ensino mesmo tumulto
iniciado eu acho que eu sou viciada em
dizer que o viciado nisso como podem ver
aqui tendo button pessoal já tem aqui
todos os materiais para fazermos as
nossas opções muito grande uma média
outra ainda mais medo educa pequena que
é maior do que esta e não sei que é por
isso que nós temos que esta pequena
também a lista que foi construindo as
pessoas que eu vou dizer qual é cmas eu
acho que vocês já sabem se você está em
foco nightwatch joão semedo já tem aqui
o nosso 40 junto todas as posições têm é
cor azul e tem também aqui uma fita
adesiva que parece sim tal então acho
que vai dar muito jeito para construir
nossa opção é porque elas têm tal em
cima se bem que esta que já tem um tal
ele está aqui já está muito parecida mas
antes construímos as nossas pessoas
pessoal eu quero descobrir muito like me
seguir se você joga fortunati deixou
muito lá e aqui para eu continuar a
fazer este tipo de coisas é porque
existem muitos haitianos no jogo existem
baú já existem net que então eu posso
construir um estudo que inclusive eu até
posso fazer uma batalha uma batalha com
ela simular o fortunato mas só cessarem
muito líquido e cometeu o que querem ver
e se vocês não forem escrito aqui no
canal pessoal em chinelos com toda a
força para eu ficar feliz
e pra vocês verem mais contido também
querem jornada que discussões vamos
fazer agora mais pequena que é mais
básica eu acho que ela dá 15% do escudo
então ela dá muito jeito no início nós
começamos a entrar no mapa
apanhar o site não dá muito jeito mas
pois lá no fim do jogo ela já não faz
assim tanta falta porque temos opções
melhores mas é sempre bom ter esta no
início e esta opção vai perceber que com
podem vir é muito parecida mesma tem
aqui olha lá o dia porque conquistei
esse povo do brasil o futuro à sua volta
que o independiente é o pessoal já
enchem nossa posição com água e agora é
muito simples agora é só adicionar
ocorrendo mas temos que adicionar um ou
dois pneus porque não vai ficar muito
azul eu não quero isso quero só que usou
básica que elas um bebê com e para lá
meu deus será que vai funcionar essa é
uma receita muito simples mas eu ainda
tenho uma luz que vai deixar as questões
muito mais bonitas olha só a lei
se eu colocar aqui por baixo olha só
mas vamos lá pessoal à en321 com muito
cuidado com muito cuidado uma pinhais
tem muito mais coisa só o efeito está
muito bonito olha só que agora vamos
trabalhar aqui e eu vou evitar o mais
possível
tá muito resulta bem em mim
[Música]
e agora o pessoal foram de resto testar
a nossa posição vamos lá ver se vão 40
autor ou seguro
o suspeito que não é porque só agora mas
vamos lá 3 aí vamos ver se dá mesmo
escudo né
agora 32 com tocou fundo não afeta em
nada a favor mas é que está pessoal a
nossa primeira opção está pronta a opção
mais fácil e agora vamos fazer a próxima
opção que tem muito mais curto para
tentar cantar na festa vai ficar muito
grande com a desculpa que a cidade está
aqui eu acho que está aqui quando thomas
eu acho que aquele escudo progressivo
que thomas comece com dez depois vai
subindo 20 30 50
patrick era um pouco maior mas vamos
mexer com água é que temos pessoal a
nossa opção com água e eu sei como é a
água toda inclusive já a mulher olha só
porque ele não escolher isto vamos
esconder a ficar inerte e não mora lá
pessoal esta é nossa segunda posição e
ela tem que ficar minimamente parecida
com esta posição que é original do jogo
e como podem vir a participar
completamente do sul mas esta aqui tem
esse comportamento em azul é porque
escolhi o dedo escolhi então ela já está
mais ou menos parecida com o original
quanto às contratações que são precisos
três quatro cinco gotas e jack onde já
tem uma taeg rua quantas 33 voltas tinha
então os preços foi preciso três para
ficar assim com mais água não pode ser 3
macaé campos só isso não vamos fazer o
cálculo e muitas presta foi 3 e tem isto
continuar d'água preste mais conhece
novas rotas
acho que há um documento 123456789 acho
que assim está bom
o ou vejam só o efeito olha é isso
o lajida ficou agora a zona por eles não
é
é muito ruim para 321 am só tá muito
parecida com a opção do jogo
[Música]
agora é hora de testar nosso pulsão
vamos lá ver se ela realmente foi feito
para 3 21 anos está a subir
estou escola vamos lá pessoal para a
próxima opção
esse pessoal vai ser a próxima o que
está a acontecer através da capital
bora bora lá pessoal esta vai ser a
próxima opção e esta é a minha opção
favorita porque ela é a opção de 50%
época ela só os 50% escuro e ela tem que
dar jeito no início do jogo como no fim
porque ela estava muito escuro mesmo só
existe uma melhor do que esta que tem
aquela tal escudo tudo mas mesmo esses
mora muito tempo a tomar então está aqui
é sempre muito boa ea posição original
no jogo é essa aqui mas não só tá muito
por si mesmo só não é muito doido como
do jogo mas não conseguia encontrar esse
potter então eu vou ter que fazer com
ele mas se vocês repararem a parte de
cima está muito igual e mais uma vez que
falta no eca
faltava o enxergavam agora vamos fazer
exatamente o mesmo ficando atrás de
outras opções vamos colocar o 41 e qual
será a medida agora não fazer apostas em
55 321 com muita calma uma duas três
quatro cinco e ainda sair eu acho que
consigo arrumar o que eu acho que no
final eu aceito
qual o meu visto como um toque foi isso
[Música]
nesta pessoal é nossa posição de escudo
de 50% e águas ainda por cima eu acho
que isto este poster água que eu acho
que isso é praxe o próprio foi um bom
time mas vejam só como está muito igual
e só aprende a ficar mais precisa a
função no jogo eu vou colocar no tal
aqui por cima eu comprei que esta fita
adesiva portanto eu acho que ela vai
fazer muito bem o trabalho e agora é só
colocar a ice t papel domínio com cola
lei é mesmo o cara vamos tentar fazer
aqui uma coisa minimamente parecida com
o do jogo é só colar aqui é só focar
nesta partida com esta fita adesiva fez
uma surpresa de muitos a mesma sorte eu
acho que vai ficar muito possível e
agora sim nós temos a opção de 50%
completa vejam só está muito igual no
jogo e tenho aqui para tentar o avaí
está muito igual
e agora ela provar agora pra ver isso
vai ser complicado que está sendo
traduzida como kasab instinto do jogo
aprensentam é importante é que os bens
bem rápido eu acho que essa pessoa mora
a cinco segundos do primeiro
a tem muita opção de escudo aqui vamos
lá ver o que vai acontecer ao meu corpo
não estava presente
[Risadas]
bora lá então pessoal a próxima opção e
esta redução maior
é aquela mais rara que mora deste mundo
sabe eu acho que o disco não escuto tudo
assim que se descobriu e essa pulsão da
equipe é mais um show é muito grande mas
além desse formato e esta opção vai ter
que ficar muito parecida com esta esta
aqui e como podem vir ela tem que um tal
a volta portanto nós vamos tentar
simular isso olha só como ficará nossa
precisão
ok pessoal está ficando muito por cima
da nossa posição mas ainda falta mais um
tal assim assim vai estar pronta a nossa
emoção e metal na nossa função agora é
só encher e colocar o corante e vamos
ver como é que vai ficar esta opção não
uma scooter quantas gotas 97 não é muito
mais agudo do que todas as outras o rumo
que o novo eu voto eu voto do zigoto 11
e 21 estão trabalho de muita calma 14
para fechar o egito olha eu acho que
está bom mesmo é super posição mas o
plenário do fórum na ilha só
[Música]
sob um sol e não queria entrar realmente
tamanho é esse pressionando um zumbi
com isso e agora é o texto final vamos
aprovar então é nossa posição do super
escuro imaginário da fortinet apenas
duas opções de política era mais forte
do jogo
estamos aptos no estômago já temos lá no
pântano do êxito stops love e vamos la
ver eu não vou transformar não saber
esta opção pode imaginar há 15 anos e
que tenham baixo voltou a vencer depois
seria um princípio como descontinuadas
ue apoia mas lá vira opção inglês já não
só existe lá no fortunato que quer ficar
com vocês agora 32 foi por essa vaga aí
eu sempre escuto o que se pode discutir
um pouco aí vou morrer
[Música]
ae
foi muito bonito aí quero fazer minha
história aqui deste vídeo talvez
quiserem que eu construí lá as coisas
relacionadas ao formato aqui no canal
que tem muita coisa ainda para construir
cometem em baixo e deixe muito light que
neste vídeo isso vocês foram inscritos
no canal tolo inscreva-se carreguei no
cine preferem todos os vídeos e adicione
um pouco mais para jogar com você sofre
no estado fiquem bem até a próxima
[Música]